le 15 décembre dernier la petite anna
chloé avait ému la france avec cette
photo largement relayé sur les réseaux
sociaux de son visage mutilé elle jeune
fille de 11 ans avait déclaré avoir été
victime d'une agression à caractère
raciste au sein de son collège des
propos qu'elle a confirmé il ya soir sur
notre plateau en présence de sa maman il
ya quelqu'un qui est arrivée
et elle a recommencé le proviseur et la
direction d'établissement maintiennent
quant à une tout autre version dénonçant
les propos diffamatoires dana chloé de
sa mère mais dans cette affaire qui dit
vrai ce soir m perez l'avocat de l'école
maîtres batik avocat d'anna chloé sont
avec nous pour tenter d'éclaircir cette
histoire
je veux remercier m pierre perez d'être
avec no mercy la période est l avocat de
l'école du proviseur de l'école
proviseur toute l'équipe enseignante
exactement et du proviseur merci et
merci à m bourrades bâti qui vient pour
souvent nous voir il a beaucoup
d'affaires un mois non ouais donc c'est
vrai m vous venez souvent de voir de
temps en temps ça va exactement merci en
tout cas vous êtes a fait avocat de la
famille d'anna clos oui alors évidemment
on va adresser à m perez qu'il ya on a
vu le témoignage d'anne à chloé c'est
vrai que sur les réseaux sociaux quand
on a vu des photos d'un à chloé
forcément vous pouvez pas rester
insensible à c'est vrai que c'était vous
avez l'air extrêmement violent et
derrière c'est vrai qu'il ya eu et
médiatiquement tout le monde s'est
emparé de la faire et tout le monde a
dit c'est inadmissible ce qui s'est
passé pour un à chloé et depuis on sait
le proviseur reçoit des menaces de mort
alors que pour vous la faire n'est pas
si simple que ça c'est ça c'est quoi la
version du proviseur alors la version du
proviseur c'est d'abord une école
417 élèves 37 professeur cinq personnels
de surveillance et c'est une école qui a
un tiers de ses élèves qui viennent de
familles défavorisées et un quart qui
viennent de familles de l'immigration
donc c'est tout sauf des racistes et si
d'ailleurs savez et et des racistes je
n'aurais pas accepté de prendre le
dossier donc ça c'est la première donc
chose que je voulais vous dire c'est le
premier cas comme ça c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais eu de ne jamais le cas similaires
où devant nombre de jeunes en prison on
a eu on a eu une fois cette année
d'ailleurs un jeune d'origine h 10
asiatiques a été adoptée qui a fait
l'objet de harcèlement ça a été signalé
tous les intéressés ont été
immédiatement renvoyés en conseil de
discipline et ça a été immédiatement
arrêté et le garçon est resté dans
l'établissement il est bien
c'est les harceleurs qui on l'a
convaincu que tout va bien et est
sanctionnée d'accord non mais c'est sur
wii est dû aux pluies dans
l'établissement maintenant tout se passe
bien pour lui et aucun problème pour lui
d'accord sur le canada chloé donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour vous re
vous vous réfutez la version de l'iphone
6 alors pour un as chloé il ya d'abord
eu des problèmes en début d'année elle a
expliqué qu'elle ne pouvait pas faire
ses devoirs ni apprendre ses leçons
parce qu'il fallait qu'elle s'occupe
dans enfants en bas âge de sa mère la
mère a été convoquée qui a expliqué
qu'elle n'avait aucun enfant en bas âge
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment là en accord avec la mère a été
organisé un suivi spécial pour cet
enfant notamment l'obligé à faire ses
devoirs pendant les études alors sa
remontée le niveau en partie pas
complètement elle est là un problème
elle ne fait pas assez de voir pourquoi
j'en sais rien ça c'est pas la
responsabilité à faire comme ça c'est
avant mais ce que je veux vous dire en
début d'année elle fait un gros mensonge
d'accord le 15 décembre
elle est dans la cour
la sonnerie d'auxonne elle veut rentrer
alors elle nous explique un garçon de sa
classe le taper deux fois donc sur la
main puis est parti devant elle et elle
elle partait donc en dernier pour entrer
dans la classe et à ce moment-là et
l'avait d'ailleurs des lacets défaits
elle court elle tombe l heure
effectivement donc un banc elle s'ouvre
le visage
qui elle est devant deux surveillants
quatre professeurs et tous les élèves
qui rentrait qui passe devant
tous disent personne ne la pousse et
c'est bien là le problème donc où elle
elle dit je quelqu'un m'a poussé par
derrière mais je me rappelle pas qui
bon très bien
elle est prise en charge par un
professeur d'éducation physique qui a
une spécialité donc en premiers secours
elle est très bien prise en charge les
pompiers arrivent la mer
mais un tel bazar que les pompiers sont
obligés de lui dire de quitter la salle
jusqu'à ce que l'enfant soit menée
l'hôpital après la diète ça je veux bien
comprendre la blessure n'était pas belle
je comprends l'émotion moi j'ai eu deux
filles et petits-enfants c'est
absolument évident que je vais pas
reprocher à qui que ce soit d'avoir été
choqués par les photos une fois qu'on a
dit ça il faut voir ce qui s'est passé
derrière
elle dit moi je on m'a poussé et tous
les témoins et dieu sait qu'il y en a
encore cet après midi qui ont été celui
dans les enfants de tous les niveaux y
compris de sa classe knees personne ne
l'a poussé ce garçon dont elle parle qui
a tapé deux fois sur le banc on
l'interrogé alors écoutez moi je suis
pas chargé de l'anc est d'accord non
mais parce que je n'ai pas accès au
dossier comme mon excellent
contradicteurs on aura accès au dossier
le moment venu pour l'instant c'est ce
qu'ont ce qu'on veut bien nous en dira
d'accord mais je pense que tous les
élèves concernés ont été entendus ou
vont l'être je crois qu'elle avait
encore cet après-midi pourquoi pourquoi
et on a eu la maman d'anne a clos hier
qui dit qu'elle réclame les images des
caméras de vidéosurveillance du collège
et promet on ne peut pas les avoir accès
à ces caméras de surveillance alors il
ya plusieurs problèmes d'abord s'aider
vieille caméras qui n'enregistrent
qu'ils ne font plus d'enregistrement
alors il est question de l'échangé c'est
un budget non négligeable donc elle ne
fonctionne pas la police l'a vérifié
deuxième chose le champ de ces caméras
ne permettait pas de toutes façons de
voir l'endroit où elle est tombée les
termes par rapport aux caméras dans un
angle mort ce qu'on a à dire
troisième chose moi qui ai créé le
centre de supervision de chambéry donc
il ya la survie la vidéosurveillance
surveillé jour et nuit donc on ne peut
pas remettre à qui que ce soit des
enregistrements on ne peut les remettre
à la justice
donc si ça avait enregistré sera été
données au procureur point final
sûrement pas elle mais sa réaction a été
de dire on veut couvrir quelqu'un on a
quelque chose à cacher pour quelle
raison on aurait quelque chose à cacher
est ce que est ce qu'on a on a pu
vérifier si elles avaient été victimes
avant de harcèlement de racisme au sein
de dieu alors doucement pas dire les
choses ont été très claires enfin
l'enfant a dit qu' elle n'a jamais
averti donc le corps professoral et la
direction d'un quelconque harcèlement
alors semer des gosses de onze ans entre
eux sont pas très sympathique car ils
peuvent se dire quelques tournées autour
de la table voilà un à oui je pense
qu'ils sont mais encore ils sont un peu
plus difficiles à gérer les insultes sa
tournée mais non je n'ai pas maman de sa
bombe qui a eu quelques mots entre
enfants dont 11 ans est tout à fait
possible mais rien est remonté à la
direction jusqu'à présent la mer nous
disaient oui mais c'est un scandale j'ai
demandé un rendez vous on ne l'a pas
accordé quand on lui a demandé mais vous
avez demandé le rendez-vous comment en
bas le maine je les trouve pas et puis
dans la dans le site qui lie les cols et
les parents qui s'appelle école ouverte
tous les mails ont été produits et
finalement c'est mail parle des retards
des phases de la façon de la faire
travailler elle est une ou des absences
rien absolument rien sur un quelconque
harcèlement donc rien n'est arrivé à
l'oreille ni des professeurs ni la
direction